jetzt schauen wir auf ein video dass uns
zugespielt wurde denn es wird für
schlagzeilen sorgen davon kann man
ausgehen tatort bremen mittwochmorgen
ein handwerker wird augenscheinlich
beraubt versucht den dieb zu halten
bekommt aber keinerlei unterstützung im
gegenteil
der techniker christian es im nahkampf
mit einem jungen mann es geht um den
rucksack des technikers
jetzt hier
christian t hält den dieb fest beide
ringen um den rucksack des handwerkers
darin unter anderem das portemonnaie ein
passant filmt doch statt dem opfer
christian es zu helfen spricht dieser
von freiheitsberaubung der täter dürfen
nicht festgehalten werden auch eine
junge frau schaut sich das ganze an
was sie machen ist das komplex jetzt
werden sie den kader ganz gut die haben
ja seine personalien jahren als
junger mann das ist freiheit bereit sein
ihr das sind alles meine sachen dann
musst du dann zu den schienen schicken
dann das unglaubliche der dreiste dieb
schnappt sich christian es portemonnaie
und läuft damit davon der dieb flieht
das portemonnaie ist weg das opfer hat
nur das nachsehen
unfassbare bilder wir sind jetzt mit
johnny hansen verbunden er ist der chef
des diebstahl opfers herr hansen wie
geht es ihrem angestellten nach diesem
dreisten überfall der könige ist
natürlich doch geschockt und vor allem
ist er davon geschockt wie sich die
mitmenschen dorf erhalten haben und die
anderen passanten
[Musik]
aber eher so war natürlich wohl auf
unsere branche und unser christian der
wird das schon verdaut werden wir helfen
dass er geschockt dass das kann man
schon verstehen was ist ihrer meinung
nach das schief gelaufen
naja erstmal muss ich sagen das ich froh
bin dass unsere mitarbeiter so besonnen
reagiert hat in dieser stresssituation
denke mal das hätte auch anders ausgehen
können die problematik ist dass unsere
fahrzeuge markt geschlossen sind in
diesem fall waren wir mit dem tank
revision fertig und wollten das öl
zurück pumpen und dazu muss der wagen
gestartet werden diese gelegenheit
genutzt und dabei hat eben halt unser
kollege christian ihn erwischt und und
rest sehen sie ja selbst was schief
gelaufen ist also jung name aber gar
keinen vorwurf machen aber es geht ja
genug leute vorbei und ich sag mal diese
spacken die sowas dann filmen ohne dann
einzugreifen da brauchen wir noch nicht
mehr darüber zu reden da war es doch
jeder das geht überhaupt nicht
glauben sie an eine notsituation weil es
ein ausländischer die proben sie das
dass die situation eventuell fairen
mitarbeiter schwieriger gemacht hat sich
zu wehren und dann nicht gleich unter
rassismus verdacht zu gelangen also
unter rassismus verdacht gerät man in
deutschland ja schon wenn man nur mal
als seine meinung gesagt
das ist das ist ja nun die kultur leider
geworden ich denke mal wir haben bei uns
im unternehmen so viele kollegen und
kolleginnen mit migrationshintergrund
das sind hervorragende
mitarbeiter und hervorragende menschen
aber in diesem fall hören sie uns sehen
sie ja selber was der phase ist und zu
kommentieren wenn am vormittag in mitten
in der stadt in bremen solche dinge
passieren ich denke mal dass der
handlungsbedarf ist ist völlig klar
ja selbstverständlich die polizei aus
dass kooperativ die haben wir auch
sofort vor ort eingeschaltet und
die polizei die die machen das schon
alles ganz prima ich denke auch die
übrig aktive tut was sie was sie so
machen kann die politik ist gefordert
und wie das in bremen so aussieht dass
kommen sie doch mal besuchen in bremen
und dann wenn sie selbst ein bild davon
machen können wie
hansen danke für das gespräch